[Musique]
lucien et marie gillet de francs comme
habite à sainte clotilde dans leur
maison familiale
aujourd'hui une équipe du glaive
intervient chez eux afin dé la gué les
arbres et éliminer les gîtes larvaires
cet opérateur soutenu par le département
accompli ici ses missions d'intérêt
général
donc votre retraite vous permet pas de
payer des gens et maintenant bas avec
l'âge c'est bien de pouvoir être aidés
parce que c'est des gens respectueux
gras et beaucoup et il fait entendre
exactement sidéral tard mais même comme
ça on le travaille à voir rien à
reprocher
[Musique]
pour bénéficier des interventions du
glaive comme la famille francs comme il
faut respecter un certain nombre de
critères le premier critère qui est
essentiel c'est la non imposition
il faut également être âgé de plus de 60
ans ou être porteurs d'un handicap
l'action du glaive va au-delà de la
simple amélioration du cadre de vie
c'est une action qui est avant tout
sociale et sanitaire et qui répond à
l'urgence sanitaire dans laquelle se
retrouve nos bénéficiaires
cette action va consister à lutter
durablement activement contre la
prolifération du chikungunya de la
leptospirose mais également d'autres
formes
[Musique]
pour plus d'informations sur ce
dispositif
vous pouvez contacter directement les
services du globe
[Musique]
je travaille bien les trois fois et je
travaille bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]